I feel like today, people like myself,
we have actually the means
and the power to fight.
And there has never
been a time in the world
actually like that until
bitcoin came in 2008.
Everything is possible actually,
because money is everything.
When Fodé Diop was a high school
senior growing up in Senegal,
he was accepted to Emporia
State University in Kansas
to study engineering
and to play basketball.
But before enrolling, the
value of the tuition money
his father had set aside
was cut in half overnight
because of a backroom deal
spearheaded by the
International Monetary Fund
and the French government.
So all the money my dad saved for me
to basically to go to college,
overnight was worth 50 percent less.
That experience is what led
to Diop's current career
as a software developer,
working to make bitcoin easy to use
as a medium of exchange
for anyone in Senegal
with a smartphone.
Bitcoin is not controlled by anybody.
Nobody can come overnight
and say that now it's worth this much
or 50 percent less or 40 percent less.
So if you are out in a country where
maybe your money might
be divided on a whim
of other nations interfering
with the local economy,
storing your money in Bitcoin
might be a better deal
for you in the future
to preserve your wealth
and preserve your money.
So it's providing a parallel stored value
and a superior one that is
not going to be the whim
of the French government,
the U.S. government, the
Senegalese government.
That's right.
Senegal has been subject
to monetary colonialism
since 1945.
When France ratified the
Bretton Woods Agreement,
which gave it control over the currency
of 14 African nations.
On the morning of January 11th, 1994,
the CFA Franc or seefa was
pegged to the French Franc
at a evaluation of 1 to 50.
The following day, it was cut to 1 to 100,
after the French government
gave into pressure
from the International
Monetary Fund and World Bank
to devalue the currency.
Not only did this temporarily
crushed Diop's college dreams,
it also led to widespread political unrest
as West African subsistence farmers
could no longer afford to
import essential goods,
including drugs to treat malaria.
It was really a big, big uproar
for these African countries,
but the local people
really found themselves
pretty much robbed because
your purchasing power
overnight was worth half.
"The cruel irony was that the economic
fate of millions of Senegalese
was completely out of their own hands,"
writes The Human Rights
Foundation's, Alex Gladstine,
"No amount of protests
could overthrow their
economic masters."
I went to the embassy, I
got rejected, they say,
actually I did not have enough money.
And I was really heartbroken.
Diop's father was eventually able
to pull together the money
and Diop got to attend college after all.
After graduating, he came across a video
featuring a Senegalese
scientist and historian
who criticized the French
African monetary system.
At this time, I wasn't really conscious
about what really happened.
Diop says it was the first
of three awakenings that set
him on his current career path.
Every once in a while,
a revolutionary product comes along
that changes everything.
The next was Steve Jobs'
famous 2007 announcement of the iPhone,
which ultimately led him to consider
how poorly traditional banks
serve the citizens of Senegal.
Every where you go in downtown
is a bank on every corner.
Bank of Africa, Bank of this,
Bank of that, bank of whatever.
And for me, I can't help but wonder,
with so many banks here,
how can we have the lowest
number of banked people
in the world?
Who are these banks serving?
The people who actually
live in these remote areas
have to pretty much travel
about two to four hours,
just to go inside a bank.
Jobs' handheld computer
created an opportunity to circumvent
these institutions all together.
My vision of the future is
that ultimately the bank,
your bank account, is going to become
pretty much through
your cell phone device.
But Jobs' revolutionary
new communication device
needed a decentralized
monetary system to match,
which is where Bitcoin comes in.
Reading Satoshi Nakamoto's
groundbreaking 2008 paper
led to Joab's third awakening.
When I read the white paper.
I said, okay, well this is a weapon
for us to fight oppression.
But the Bitcoin network alone
isn't well-suited to
becoming a medium of exchange
for everyday purchases in
Senegal or anywhere else.
That's because it
currently has the capacity
to process only a handful
of transactions per second,
which is where the Bitcoin
Lightning Network comes in.
So Bitcoin, for it to
rival the likes of Visa
and MasterCard, it
would have to do upwards
of like 20,000 transactions per second,
or like even 25,000.
Today unfortunately Bitcoin only does
7 to about 12 transactions per second.
Lightning Network works like a bar tab.
When you go to the bar,
you open up a tab and you
pretty much go back and forth
and take as many transactions as you want.
And then you settle your
bill at the end of the night.
So Bitcoin is a base layer,
but unfortunately it's not
really fast or nor is it cheap.
So basically what happens is you and I,
we opened up a channel or like
a Lightning Network channel.
Basically we put some
funds in there that we lock
and then we protect as many as we want,
millions of times,
basically at the end of the month,
we basically go settle on
the Bitcoin layer itself,
which is a little bit more expensive
because of course it's the base layer,
but lightening wise,
our transactions will
pretty much cost a fraction
of a penny.
So it's almost instant and almost free.
And then at the point,
we can rival the MasterCard
and the Visas of the world.
With Bitcoin,
the Lightning Network, and
ubiquitous smartphones,
Diop thinks it's possible
to build a new free market
monetary system that will
finally liberate Senegal
and other African countries
from the last vestiges of colonialism.
I feel like maybe governments
are still threatened maybe,
but to me, open source
technology is just beautiful.
And I believe actually that
our work is so important
that we have to do it no matter
what the consequences are.
So if we can leverage this technology
to fight the oppressor, right,
and technology, open source technology
is actually what we need right now.
And it's here.
So why not use it?